[Musik]
ja tablette nehmen trinken
krank und obdachlos doktor thomas
beutler kümmert sich auch noch um seine
patienten
man sieht ein mensch tut sich irgendwie
nichts gutes und schadet sich so massiv
und man versucht ihn zu erreichen und
erreichten erst mal nicht das ist immer
frustrieren aber wichtig ist dass wir
uns im blick behalten und dass wir in
locker lassen
in essen versorgt ärztin ursula fuchs
die wunden wohnungsloser menschen
wir können uns aber auch noch ein
stückchen weiter eröffnen wollen sie
nicht nur wenn sie nicht holen
wir gehen das auch schon okay viele
menschen stellen sich das team vor was
ist überhaupt nicht schlimm
man sieht viele in farbe und das elend
gibt es auf der ganzen welt und das ist
einfach da aber manchmal kann man ja
auch was tun
der hamburger winter hat lebte sonntags
patienten schwer zugesetzt
merck kgaa ziemlich krank das weiß so
nah und es wäre gut wenn sie nicht bei
diesem wetter hier im haus haffter
straße ich liebe ja selber nicht
ich weiß nicht wie man so leben kann ich
kann es mir nicht vorstellen
[Musik]
jedes wochenende ist das arztmobil
hamburg unterwegs um die obdachlosen der
stadt zu versorgen
liefke sonntag ist ärztin an ihren
freien wochenende arbeitet sie
ehrenamtlich dann wenn die anderen
hilfseinrichtungen geschlossen sind
wir schlafen hier im haus seien gegen
auf der straße gekommen
völlig durchnässt im bus das ist schon
eine schlimme vorstellung dass wir auch
so leben müssen also ich bin sehr froh
dass ich nicht obdachlos bin dass ich
meine wohnung nach jeden zweiten sonntag
steuert das arztmobil die reeperbahn an
die vergnügungsmeile ist bekannt für
partys und prostitution aber auch viele
gestrandete landen hier warten auf eine
warme mahlzeit und auf den doktor
wir kennen die zeiten die wissen heute
jetzt ab 12 was zu futtern und dann
kommen sie halt alle fange man auch die
essensausgabe organisiert lebte mit
ihren kollegen das angebot lockt die
patienten an dem bus arbeiten alle
ehrenamtlich das arztmobil wird allein
durch spenden finanziert
das auf das klingt der junge mann
schläft auf der straße seit wochen schon
läuft er mit den schmerzen herum
du warst im hospital und dann war der
hat oft richtig offene wunden an den
themen dass es schmerzhaft dass es
entzündet dann braucht sich ja auch ein
antibiotikum aber vorher muss man noch
mal ran gutachten hingucken eine
kulturen lägen et cetera et war das
übersteigt unsere basis medizin wir ein
wenig krankenschwester steffi versorgt
die wunde
mehr geht nicht einer der gründe warum
ich das gerne hier mache und sicherlich
nicht weil wir ja alle die helfer
symptome haben sondern das sind
versorgung die wenn man wer soll das
machen soll
eigentlich müsste der patient täglich
behandelt werden
wenn wir sagen hier kommen wir an unsere
grenzen du musst das im verlauf röntgen
lassen kontrolle machen lassen können
wir die nur weiterschicken ob sie dann
weiterziehen und eine weitere behandlung
irgendwo machen lassen das wissen wir
nicht
viele von lew des patienten campieren
tag und nacht auf der reeperbahn engel
ist eine von ihnen
da würden stand haben das ist straße
hallo leicht aber immer mit der ernst
meinen
immer habe ich ganz am anfang nie
kennengelernt da waren sie echt halbtot
also werden sie glaube ich bei einem
unserer ersten einsätze hier einmal ins
krankenhaus gebracht weil sie in so
einem desolaten zustand war und die ist
nun wieder aufstehen denn ich hätte nie
schafft es immer wieder
ich finde sie großartig dass es hier so
ein bisschen wie modi von dieser platte
und die hat auch nur ordentliche
kodderschnauze und da muss man sich den
respekt hart erarbeiten
nachdem er offenbar sollen nicht trüben
können
mein klient
was kommt als nächstes den einkommen
vollzeit
[Musik]
das team der münchner straßenambulanz
ist dreimal in der woche unterwegs
tagsüber arbeitet thomas beutler in
einer praxis für wohnungslose abends
besucht er mit pfleger bernd gollwitzer
die schlafstätten der obdachlosen
sie haben einen hinweis bekommen unter
einer brücke an der theresienwiese
sollen menschen campieren um den
gefrierpunkt hatte oder zwei grad das
buch kommt okay ist aber dass es noch
runter geht man gegen acht oder zehn
grad minus der unternehmen dass man von
wir schauen wie es ihm geht aber sein
wir haben sie seien es gut
im magen ok brauchen sie noch panto
zonen noch später ja brauchen sie
brauche ich peter kaminski schöne alles
gute es hat sich herumgesprochen dass
der doktor da ist ist das gegen hohen
blutdruck nichts verstehen gut deutsch
sprechen
okay wir gehen noch mal vor zum
dolmetscher er hat nur noch einen er ich
komme morgen kommen sie in die praxis
kolumbusplatz ja er kommt in die praxis
und holt medikament okay also medikament
können wir geben
okay okay okay danke schön sein dass man
mit
präsenz zeigen vertrauen aufbauen
für die arbeit der obdachlosen ärzte ist
vor allem eines wichtig das gespräch mit
den menschen
wir haben einen optimalen rund 500
obdachlose gibt es in münchen so die
statistik die dunkelziffer ist hoch
viele von ihnen leben schon lange
draußen und wollen selbst in eisigen
nächten nicht in den kälteschutz die
impfung
was für eine theoretisch können wir
sicher helfen wollen stellen mit ins
auto kommt ja dann komme ich damit
dieser mensch der arm ist der krank ist
der kein obdach hat das ist im grunde
eigentlich die reinste form des
menschlichen elends den menschlichen not
und wenn man einer sein kann
der in diesem moment da ist mit dem
anderen helfen kann
egal welcher art und weise dann ist es
ein sehr erfülltes befriedigen das
gefühl es könnte auf fast sagen es macht
ihn fast glücklich
früher arbeitete thomas beutler in der
chirurgie einer münchner klinik
vor zwei jahren wechselte der 53-jährige
in die praxis für wohnungslose die auch
das arztmobil betreibt fast nichts haben
dass die durch vielleicht vollen
zufriedenheit im moment wären weil sie
eben diesen wahnsinn
essen im ruhrgebiet auch hier sind die
obdachlosen zahlen gestiegen 1550 sollen
es sein
ursula fuchs von der gesellschaft für
soziale dienstleistungen essen versorgt
sie wurde ich gefragt ob ich das machen
möchte
habe ich mir das angeschaut hab ich
gesagt ja werden
täglich steht das arztmobil vor dem
gesundheitszentrum in essen
viele obdachlose haben hier ihre
meldeadresse und kompost abzuholen
ein besuch beim arzt kann da gleich
miterledigt werden
er war eine nacht keine nach draußen
warum also nicht ja wenig später
bewusstlos geworden
er hat sich dann erfrierungen zugezogen
an den händen ich kann froh sein dass
man mich nun gefunden
ich hatte aufgegeben ich bin in die
falsche richtung gehofft das ist alles
worum ich hatte zu viel konsumiert und
konnte mich nirgendwo festhalten
die füße des 50 jährigen sind offen
nur die regelmäßige versorgung der
wunden macht eine besserung möglich die
füße hoch oder also einen erstmal das
wollte ich eine lebensgefährliche
situation die diese minusgraden
geschuldet warum natürlich diesen hohen
konsum muss natürlich sehr unglücklich
dann wie das alles zusammen gekommen ist
und das ist schon ausgeprägt ist die
erfahrung die er hat aber was ja vorher
nicht so ganz klar war ob es jetzt
zeichnet sich schon ab dass sie die
zähne behalten wird das wenig abfallen
werden und nicht amputiert werden müssen
das schon mal sehr schön machen bis
montag wurden die wunden werden heilen
doch auch in dieser kalten nacht wird
der patient wieder draußen schlafen in
hamburg steht das arztmobil wieder auf
der reeperbahn
der andrang ist groß auch engel ist
wieder da passt der ruf der stadt alles
gut an scheibe lange hast du ja schon
dass selbst habe gm verbrannt aber das
ist äußerlich oder liga also die ohren
selbst in drin tun ja nicht wem und
schwer zu dem fahrzeug werde jetzt das
alles wird dazu die knochen nicht noch
einmal sehen ist das unten hier geht so
muss sagen für euch und ihr auch bis zum
nächsten rennen hast du dich nicht
ärgern sehen ziemlich viel hilfe ab sie
ist sehr sehr stur so und
ich glaube dass es schwer ist wenn du so
viele viele jahre auf der straße gelebt
hast dass einzelkämpfer und jeder neue
tag ist neuer kampf ich glaube die würde
dazu den eigenen vier wänden gar nicht
ausreichend
hamburg hat offiziell rund 2000
obdachlose
viele sind ohne krankenversicherung ein
bruchteil kommt zur kostenfreien
behandlung ins arztmobil auf der
reeperbahn gibt es ein regelrechtes
stammpublikum
es geht hier am meisten hoch her also
wir haben ja auch manchmal ein bisschen
sehr ungeduldige patienten eine prügelei
vor der tür oder so das haben wir an
anderen standorten so nicht ich glaube
dass es einfach revermann hits wie
wohnen hier alle heimlicher geht's mir
alles gut alles gut
micha ist um die 50 er liegt schon lange
auf der straße seine freundin mirka ist
schwach durch eine krankheit ist ihr
immunsystem beeinträchtigt
jetzt ist eine starke erkältung dazu
gekommen
du warst doch meiner praxis von dieser
einen ärztin gewesen da muss so wieder
hin versucht massiv zu atmen bitte in
den zustand soll bürger nicht draußen
schlafen
warum geht ihr nicht ins
winternotprogramm fliesen cher wird lass
mich es wäre besser wenn ich was tun
aber er möchte es nicht aber ich möchte
auch nicht mal froh torreichen lask-fans
will ich nochmal hinsetzen soll ich mit
michael reden
merkt ziemlich krank das weiß so nah
und es wäre gut wenn sie nicht bei
diesem wetter hier im gut draußen auf
der straße die wir selber nicht
sie hat mir eben gesagt sie würde gerne
aber tun möchte das nicht deswegen
wollte ich mit dir nochmal sprechen
es gibt auch zimmer verpacker jeden tag
zehn kilometer
rosenkranz platz und sammelte täter
wenige babys und klein vor dies ist alle
krank das weiß tun
so deutlich so tust du mir einen
gefallen denkst du noch mal drüber nach
bitter wenn es jetzt kälter werden
sollte und wenn es friert sollte denkst
du wenigstens darüber nach bitte können
wir das machen sie darüber nachdenken
gekommen weil ich habe 38 jahre hinter
mir und ich stehe man aber war
eigentlich immer fahrer nach pilzen
und das schafft sie zu hause ich will es
trotzdem mal gesagt haben denkt trotzdem
wird es rüber nach ok ja er spricht zu
mir das große oder antwort übte
ja
matter wird zu ich geb dir ein
antibiotikum
ich möchte dass du das nimmst eine
morgens einer abends regelmäßig
regelmäßig okay nein das vergisst du
nicht
gehen wir noch
du fängst heute abend an hört zu bitte
gefängnis heute abend an morgen früh
wieder morgen an zwei am tag
wenn sie diese winter übersteht dann
kann sie froh sein
du kannst den leuten nicht sagen ich
will jetzt das so dass um das tust das
ist seine entscheidung und wenn es ihr
wichtiger ist mit ihrem mann oder freund
zeit zu verbringen als das hier im
trockenen und warmen schläft dann ist es
auch ihre entscheidung aber es ist sehr
traurig dass du mir auch total leid weil
diese nicht allzu alt werden
[Musik]
die gesellschaft für soziale
dienstleistungen essen wird
hauptsächlich durch die stadt finanziert
sie betreibt das arztmobil und auch ein
wohnheim für ältere wohnungslose hier
lebt norbert sprenger
ich habe dann alles durch den alkohol
alles selber versaut alles die hat mit
mir mal großes vorgehabt auch das sollte
dies so kommen es gibt gewinner es gibt
vielleicht sehe ich unter die folie
wie geht es ihnen gut gut brauchen sie
sonst noch medikamente
da gebe ich ihnen noch mal wiederkommen
sie einen schönen bilder haben soweit
alles profis dann kommen sie einfach
nächste woche wieder wenn sie wieder was
sie benötigen das für manche auch
schwierig dann halt zum haushalt zu
laufen dann ist das bestimmt terminen da
hinzugehen auch lange zeit zu warten und
so und dann erleichtern wir dass unsere
patienten die es einfach hinkommen
können wählen so ein bisschen kümmern
norbert sprenger hatte keinen festen
wohnsitz
er hat in abbruchhäusern gelebt man hört
ja so viel dass er obdachloser
erschlagen oder anstecken benzin über
ein kippen
das risiko wohl nicht mehr eingehen das
war ja kein schlafen in dem sinne dass
man mit ein auge dann ist man immer wach
gewesen
auf jedes geräusch hat man gehört und da
bin strich gezogen bin hierher gegangen
es hat nie eine karriere im klassischen
medizinbetrieb angestrebt früher war sie
ärztin in der anästhesie nun versorgt
sie die menschen am rande der
gesellschaft
aber die die keine wohnung haben oder
süchte haben sie ein bisschen
schwieriger sich schwerer hilfe machen
wir dann halt und dann das ist auch in
ordnung so kommen sie ruhig mal ein
bisschen ist trotzdem nehme sich schon
mal platz
ich kann keine schuhe richtig anziehen
deswegen sollte ich ihn schwierig mit
der fußpflege uns jetzt - gerade
angesagt sie sagen schon neulich damen
die bereiche wohnen bringt nicht durch
wollte das ist halt so kann ich auch
nicht ganz so stark messe eigentlich
müssten die beine regelmäßig gewickelt
werden und das ist halt natürlich
schwierig wenn man auf der straße lebt
und dem zug schlafen muss aber jetzt
steht ja die große die große
wahrscheinlichkeit dass patienten andere
stationäre einrichtung kann
tschuldigung und dann jetzt schon besser
werden
ich bin ja mein eigener herr und kann
natürlich mit jedem patienten so lange
sprechen wie ich das möchte ich mir
nicht gezwungen eine zweiminuten oder
fünf minuten medizin zu machen wenn
jemand nicht alles fertig ist dann ist
es hier nur rund eine halbe stunde
braucht dann ist es genau so in ordnung
und so das kann ich halt ab weg und das
ist schon natürlich ein großes privileg
und auch arzt im ursprünglichen sinne
und das ist natürlich richtig spaß
die junge frau wird die stationäre
einrichtung zwar auf suchen sie aber
nach kurzer zeit wieder verlassen
im arztmobil von ursula schocks ist sie
seitdem nicht wieder aufgetaucht
[Musik]
in münchen ist thomas beutler wieder mit
der straßenambulanz unterwegs ich würde
einfach umfang
der 53 jährige kennt die stammplätze
aber auch sozialarbeiter oder besorgte
bürger informieren ihn wenn sie
obdachlose gesehen haben auf dem
münchner königsplatz campiert eine
kleine gruppe die kälte kann schnell
lebensbedrohlich werden
schon auch so dass man dann am nächsten
tag nach der arbeit so schnell schauen
oder sich erkundigt und vorbeifahren
shorts in die sachen noch da tagsüber
arbeitet thomas beutler in der praxis
für wohnungslose träger ist der
katholische männer fürsorge verein
münchen viele die der arzt draußen
anspricht konnte er schon hierher locken
es gibt stammkunden die üblichen ja elf
jahre lebte volker boehme auf der straße
und war alkoholabhängig war ich halte
sie sollen die zentren für mich die
kohle mich dann tue ich wo verkaufen
gemacht wenn wir das dann mal hört dass
die 17 züge gemacht haben und plötzlich
der 17 danach war dann worten und da
hätten wir spätestens ab dem dritten
vierten zug sagen können was holz was
bringt das das kann man doch bleiben
lassen der erreger wird nicht trocken
oder lang 12 wurde am 14
aber gott sei dank gott sei dank haben
die kolleginnen oder kollegen
durchgehalten haben ihn immer wieder
motiviert auch sich selber motiviert
nahm es dann erreicht dann hat dieser
menschheit den sitzen und hinzu
gebraucht damit taten werden
volker boehme ist seit fünf jahren
trocken jetzt lebt er in einer
einrichtung für ältere wohnungslose
früher hatte in der münchner
großmarkthalle gearbeitet und draußen
geschlafen
noch einmal geht er zurück an den ort
der elf jahre sein zuhause war
[Applaus]
in dir ist da morgens sind die
schlafsäcke gemacht aber die schlafsäcke
in folie sodann mit generator ankommen
ich hatte die aktion mein schlaf sagt er
untertags geschlagen damals waren sie zu
sechst zwei freunde hat böhme hier
verloren wir sind gestorben und
wohlstand warnte davor in die kommende
nacht schicht und her
man sieht da weiter eigentlich nie
zurück hier nämlich das angucken
doch so alte erinnerungen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in hamburg hat der kalte winter erste
opfer gefordert
fünf menschen sind bereits erfroren der
letzte war mich ja von der reeperbahn
[Musik]
ich war wahnsinnig traurig muss ich
sagen ich stecke ja viel weg aber ich
kannte ihn nun echt schon über zwei
jahre und da war für mich ein ganz
besonderer ganz liebenswürdiger lustiger
sehr herzlicher mensch ich habe mich
immer sehr gefreut ihn zu sehen
[Musik]
er wurde eingeliefert mit einer
körpertemperatur von 23 grad
und das hat ihm letztendlich mit den
ganzen folgeschäden dann leider das
genick gebrochen
michael kam noch lebend ins krankenhaus
zwei tage kämpften die ärzte um ihn
vergeblich hatte das irgendwie
mitgekriegt dass erhalt noch am leben
ist und hat sich dann auf den weg
gemacht und ihnen auf der
intensivstation besucht und das rechne
ich ihm hoch an weil die show unter
aufwand für sie in ein krankenhaus zu
gehen sich da zu behaupten und zu sagen
ich möchte den jetzt sehen muss
unglaublich groß sein und das hat sie
alles auf sich genommen das für mich
großartig
er war hier kamen noch getrunken hat
alle zeit später um die ecke aber an
kollegen micha langsamer zurückgehen und
deshalb gehört
die letzte im krankenhaus
ja ich hab schon gedacht
weil er hier wieder belegt worden
so lagen kann es ausstellen haben also
aus stellt sich angeboten
er hat schon auf euch auf genial
goldring ich will ein zweiter mich
[Musik]
für lief der heißt es weiter machen vor
dem winternotprogramm der stadt warten
schon die nächsten patienten auf hilfe
vom arzt mobil
ich finde schon dass in der reichen
stadt wie hamburg müsse niemand auf der
straße leben müssen ist so aber ich bin
sehr froh darüber dass sich immer mehr
leute engagieren und wie viele leute
sich bei uns melden und schreiben sagen
hey wir finden das toll comment helfen
das stimmt mich dann doch sehr froh
in immer mehr städten sind ärzte für die
ärmsten im einsatz
das problem obdachlosigkeit können sie
nicht lösen die not der menschen lindern
schon